das ist natürlich stunde da muss man
sagen man darf das infektionsrisiko in
einer solchen situation auch nicht
unterschätzen weil die menschen die auf
englisch miteinander sprechen und
ländern miteinander spricht auch draußen
noch abstand und trägt eine maske fehler
da waren da zu sehen die arten kamaz
kann dann ist über die trends viele
infektionen die infektionen durchaus
möglich und auch nicht unwahrscheinlich
und außerdem reist man entweder im auto
oder in der bahn und gerade anreise im
auto ist ein hochrisiko bereich wenn das
jetzt sag mal ein familienmitglied schon
hart wenn ein familienmitglied initiiert
ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass alle
familienmitglieder sich auf einer
solchen autofahrt dann infizieren auch
deutlich erhöht womit das ist also
gefährlich